hey man today on our show we're gonna
flash our balls
undress Batman and guess what man we're
gonna introduce you to me and mr. mr.
Jones mr. Jones that is so much more on
the DC direct version of fat man I'm
Batman let's go you like that ivory tone
that's right now I'm Kevin Smith mark
barnard welcome to fat man I'm Batman
this is the DC the DC direct version of
the show man we're all we talk about is
DC related stuff last edition was Marvel
this is all about DC that covers the
comics that covers the movies that
covers the TV shows and we're gonna dive
into it soon but before we do that I
just want to share something with you
men like I was on an episode of battle
on Hollywood babble-on podcast I do last
Friday and we put up the trailer for
Batman vs Superman and as the trailer
was playing you know they showed bends
Bruce Wayne getting out of the little
car fat guy in a little and he gets out
of his little car and while I was
watching it in the room you know we were
at the mics because the show's life and
I was a hey it's that [ __ ] from
fashionable male just a real throwaway
Mallrats Joe somebody heard that on the
podcast and turned it into this tweet
there was a two-parter he did both parts
that's awesome and there's the other one
which is like you talked about and Ben
has that Bruce says that little smirk
who don't know what they do name of the
dude on Twitter was did somebody tell me
real quick a genius a 68 or something
yeah
engines yes engine studio engine 86 to
do so anyway I love the internet for
that very reason man like I made a half
joke that dude turn into a reality
yeah you know the other like 10,000
likes in my Instagram account man okay
so gene the other thing that's a little
weird is that apparently there is a meme
going around that I'm a black guy what
do you mean I know it's kind of strange
I'm glad I discovered this thanks to
this picture there's a picture of like
Tim white lady going
we're Norden is black there's another
one of bound glover going damn right
Bernard is black is weird it's so weird
like there was I saw somebody tweeted
again we're still dealing with the fact
that some people have nothing and I saw
there's a tweet from somebody who was
just like I thought it was weird how two
white boys went on about inclusion and
diversity so much but somebody said I
just thought you were a dulcet voice
french-canadian oh my god they thought
you were Canadian they fed I was looking
at because of the name you made my day
with that thing man plus it maybe turned
it in and scram clickbait thanks man
more that lets everything else alright
let's talk about the big news man's big
news Brzezinski about the DC Universe
we're going to start off where do you
want to go first where should we go
first you don't man costumey [ __ ]
yeah wanted can we there an order to the
how we have to talk let's talk Justice
League will start talking about Justice
League so throw up a Justice League
graphic of some sort
yeah because people like Justice League
what's that oh just in case you forgot
there it is what that's the you know
they're the DC Universe equivalent of
the Avengers shot there's a new Trinity
if you will before we go deep into into
that we got a story here man about a
costume designer works on works on this
Batman V Superman picture
Michael Wilkinson was that this
comic-con I guess it was in Brazil yeah
that a huge Comic Con where they showed
like footage that we haven't seen here
in the States
I've been following Jim Lee's Instagram
cuz he was down there it looked bananas
it looked crazy like it made our
comic-con look like oh yeah yeah that's
adorable that looks like a wizard cop we
were not so much I was so hard real like
if you're gonna fly me I will put on the
little bikinis that were the Jesus
statue is if they for comic-con if they
put like a cow on that oh my god been
amazing he's just up on the hill
that'll earn you kids don't [ __ ] with
Jesus don't you don't [ __ ] with Jesus
okay so costume designer gave out some
information yeah
about probably more than he should have
probably the most loose lips sink ships
my person might be fired but talked
about confirmed things that no studio
people or anyone else involved with the
movie including Zack Snyder have
confirmed for us including you know
number one that footage of Batman in the
desert even wearing a silent bob
trenchcoat and stuff and fighting pair
what could be parademons possibly that
is Batman's I know I I am wrong on you
hoped it was wonderful I hope yes you
know whatever I'm glad to take the
bullet on this one I mean it would have
been better but whatever listen to this
so they were shooting the film in London
for a year six months of prepping six
months of shooting for Aquaman this is
all costumey stuff they got the idea to
use tattoos for Aquaman from Jason Momoa
himself he's got these fantastic tattoos
of his own and the costume designer
Michael says I got my mind thinking
about how to go in a really interesting
new direction for the scales that we
usually see on Aquaman so we decide to
do them tattoos and some cool armor
I think Aquaman does look badass yeah I
think it looks really really cool it's
not the Algar Man I grew up with you
know the orange shirts gone so the
orange shirts gone in favor of actual
pecs yeah kind of nuts I remember seeing
some some another meme online where
somebody interviewed hit Jason Momoa at
an airport it was like so does your
Aquaman swim he's like yeah he's Aquaman
it's like did you have to learn how to
swim for the role it's like I'm Hawaiian
bro
Batman in their universe he's been
fighting crime for 20 years does not
need gadgets or armor he's like the
James Bond interesting real power is a
strength lots of engineering in the suit
so he can turn his head with the cowl on
they had to build a better mousetrap for
that
then doesn't the suit become a gadget
costume person no you're absolutely
right it is kind of a gadget I think
what they're Manning to say is it's not
maybe animate well this is weird because
they're saying he doesn't rely heavily
on gadgets but in the trailer it's a
batwing shooting bullets and a gun
current which we found out is a grenade
launcher is that this Batman likes guns
because he's like you know obviously
Batman would only use that against
something is big and unfinished looking
as dude and also for the record a lot of
people like you you're crapping on that
movie no I'm not I can't wait to see
them and I'm in love man all over his
face neck and chest he went they said
totally but they said that we didn't you
know we were kinder to Civil War
something like that but hey look I can
be a little disappointed with the
trailer dick it's two minutes of a thing
yeah and I'm and I again we said the leg
work totally gonna go see it and whatnot
but yeah I saw a few people liking me
book could turn your back on sex night
was like no I didn't come there
regardless Zack Snyder wanted a Batman
it's a little bit older this Batman
doesn't need gavage gadgets he already
said all that we wanted to have a bat
suit that he could look over his
shoulder and do all these moves that was
very important to us there's a whole lot
of engineering in the cowl of the bat so
no more of the Christian Bale like which
to be fair he like you know turned it
into a helmet and that made sense but I
have a feeling it's a mixture when they
say there's a lot of engineering in it I
think there's a lot of CG to get rid of
any rubber bunching or what rubber baby
BB punching say Robin is my new rap
that's the engineering that's my guess
oh yeah nightmare Batman sequence Batman
vision man not one of them I'm sorry
yeah whatever
a great idea of this sort of nightmarish
vision almost a vision of the future a
post apocalyptic vision it's like a
dream that Ben has I guess they mean
Bruce so we wanted to have it almost a
Mad Max quality to it where it's like
the end of the world trying to survive
and then of course Superman has men
come so those are minions including the
flying things they didn't say anything
about parademons so it's sort of easy
way of representing the amazing amounts
of the sort of obsessive quality that
Bruce Wayne has about the threat of
Superman so it's a dream Signori got it
which like I'm happy to see him in that
with the desert fatigues like you know I
know it's a dream and they got to use a
lot of that footage and the trailers now
but how awesome to see like we're
getting so spoiled the first time you
saw that image of him in that that
overcoat and a duster in the desert we
were all we were like oh my god that's
nuts I've never seen that in the movie
like I haven't even seen a snow variant
of Batman's costume and I got 12 of
those action figures so once they showed
that image I was a koala looks
Elseworlds evening that's kind of badass
so at least they're shown us something
different like his whole suit is
different and Zack Snyder could have
gotten away with like you got a
brand-new suit he looks like Dark Knight
go [ __ ] yourselves but instead he throws
in look at a desert Batman or nightmare
Batman or something I hope to see three
more costume changes in this picture
mark woo fun at the beach back I'm
mourning my parents Batman stuff like
that Batman shorts we've seen very you
know like didn't they do that on the
Batman TV show you said at one point all
right so the flash we get a glimpse of
them in dawn of Justice as that ain't
the glimpse that's a little graphic but
in case y'all don't remember what the
flash looks like but the dawn of Justice
you get only glimpse of him he has a
different silhouette than the rest of
the league I don't know what that means
the costume designer said has a
different silhouette than the other ones
and I think that's what makes the
Justice League so amazing the flash is
more like an Olympic marathon runner or
something like that he shredded and he's
not as bulky and as huge as a lot of the
other guys in league so maybe that's
what they mean he's not gonna be like
ripped like Momoa right just everybody
just staying in there as if they're
gonna lift something it was the cuts a
different silhouette man as does Wonder
Woman that's our next one yes they said
we wanted her strength of power to be
tangible we want I mean touch of we
wanted to her to stand next to the two
male counterparts and be very much
they're equal she has this incredible
power
strength she also combines with grace
and compassion and majesty to make such
good boys just seriously sucking her
[ __ ] dick isn't it also none of that
has anything to do with turn into easy
waxing rhapsodic better character we all
love I try to find the upside to all
these yes it's way better than me love
god I hate that [ __ ] character yeah
he's like or I dressed her in [ __ ]
pants or something like they gave her a
battle skirt a battle skirt I gave her
leggings that would have touched off a
controversy she have a check in the gun
she I bet she will have like is at one
point and totally can why not
yeah they showed her in the outfit she's
wearing a variation of the Alpha that
everyone recognizes this yeah you know
what she's gonna have a costume changes
I hope [ __ ] smart they want to sell a
few more figures I'm telling you man
like just vary the outfit up a little
bit tired of buying figures where it's
like he's green that never happened to
them Superman be amazing and then break
off a few more toys and [ __ ] I don't
care I'll buy Superman here you go man
big guy costumes a little different from
Anna steel and has a Joseph Campbell
quote weaved into it you know cuz he was
Joseph Campbell is the king of Krypton
yes the man of his hands and face the
quote is where we thought to stand alone
we will be with all the world but it's
written in Kryptonian it let it says
that so boy that's inside Facebook
pretty much three people on the planet
are gonna see this and so one of them
was wearing the consciousness is the
equivalent of like those old Disney
animators who used to put like naked
frames baby Hubert risen in great the
Superman costume says the costume
designer we have all new material the
suit is a little bit more sheer so you
really get the sense of this metal
under suit coming through the blue over
suit and we have new fabric for the Cape
Cape was mostly digital in the last
president like every time they cut to
the Cape it's made of metal under suit
because he's Superman to protect me from
the super [ __ ] cuz he's metal dude this
is a metal beam or metal I'm still I'm
look I'm in I'm crazy in I can't wait to
see this movie in a big bad way there's
another store and people are gonna think
I'm kicking its balls but we tried to
talk about everything related to the
subject matter the dawn of Justice
trailer went up and again as I said a
last episode I watched it five times and
then liked it a lot quite a bit so I'm a
fan now what is that's the numbers or
numbers just in posters over here grim
numbers we need to share with you now
bear with this means muffin nothing or
maybe it means everything civil war
trailer which was the first of its kind
the very first civil war trailer dropped
last week 61 million downloads yes a lot
that's robust number pretty [ __ ]
robust dawn of Justice let's go to
Sheffield
yes dawn of Justice was they'll switch
two days later John of Justice drops two
days later but there's not the first
trailer let's be fair correct it is the
fourth if you want to count that first
costume tease what was the first
costumes it was just literally like a
camera revolving around like the bat
cowl and there was a voiceover oh that's
right then the San Diego Comic Con
trailer which everyone eventually saw
that's the first big trail this is the
second big trailer and then there was
the pulling the mask off right oh my god
am happy also but not while watching got
him we saw it online later so though
technically this is the fourth Batman V
Superman trailer again so give it a
little space Civil War downloads for the
first trailer 61-million dawn of Justice
second trailer dos dos 22 million down
and almost the same spam time can we
look up how many downloads the first
Batman V Superman trailer had yeah I
mean maybe that'll be back comparison
but some people are trying to use this
online to be like nobody gives a [ __ ]
about is my [ __ ] its movies gonna
make a bazillion dollars man and I would
also wonder what the comparison is to
the first Star Wars trailer excellent
point which everyone though this is
giving this this Batman movie the BVS
for sure it is we say trailer is giving
everyone ample opportunity to praise the
marketing of force awakens for hiding
everything for showing you things that
make you want to see the movie but
hiding almost everything oh nothing
about what happens it don't know what's
going on in that movie nope hopefully we
will when we see the movie I'll be sad
if you walked out like I'm puzzled to
see it through the lens flare but I'm
telling you man like it's it's I don't
think it's a sign I don't that some
people are trying to write articles like
are they in trouble yeah well I mean
welcome to the Internet where they have
to have a thing to write about every day
all day it's true so I got my attention
what's the story this why cuz there's a
story when a force awakens got a rating
like force awakens rated pg-13 so [ __ ]
news every movie gets a rating because
what are you surprised that it wasn't an
R like I was hopeful for hard armed and
c-17 [ __ ] I was hoping to see
somebody coming anymore no what's
awakening why am I going dad no of
course it's gonna be pg-13 means no
nudity yeah but think you're right man
is a [ __ ] constant news cycles again
something's gotta feel it you gotta feed
it I mean part of the problem we're not
brother solution we're literally talking
about things
with other people and godlike sounds
cool to me or would you rather watch
this and pitching alternate versions but
yeah man fandom will lead you to do some
wacky stuff it totally will I would not
worry about those numbers 22 million
verse 61 million yeah my mother
look marvel don't need my mother but she
doesn't know the civil wars coming she
has not said to me why are our man
captain america mad at each other tiger
but she has said why are Batman and
Superman fighting I thought they were
Super Mom ooh yeah dormammu's named the
geeks truly would have been aired of the
earth so so in lower than the 61 million
that civil wars first trailer has pulled
in a very short amount of time yeah
Marvel's on point men like eight years
of building a brand it pays off yeah you
know how to drop a trail or open a movie
and stuff and and marvel I mean Warner
Brothers DC you figuring that out now
but these are not like you know yeah
it's like you can't have a 12-inch dick
but I'll let you keep your 9 inch dick
like awesome thanks that's coming from a
man with a three inch deck see still
hits the ground it just doesn't leave
his big of a trough mine hits the grass
some bunches me the back of neck mouth
open in the turlet and people like
didn't he make Clarks one Thursday so
it's crushing both of them that's the
first star worship Wow I mean Star Wars
in a brand if you're gonna do a brand
observation just based on those trailers
Star Wars sit how many 72
oh my god that's not even cash just
Fandango not counting anything else
heaven so star wars Civil War and then
don't adjust it nostalgia is a hell of a
drug man you ain't kiddin man like yeah
it's any chance of something original
maybe popping up my star was original
hey man argument on movie fights since
there's an episode 7 yes aren't Star
Wars Empire Return of the Jedi now
technically prequels as well they do
qualify here anymore this [ __ ] like
[ __ ] the prequels chick is now you talk
about empire fools think about it right
you just married into that family man
[ __ ] all day mark set it to correctly
man I said some people online going no
that's the original trilogy and the
other ones the prequels but if we're
dealing with an episode 7 episode 1
through 6 would be technically what mark
prequels it is according to English can
we put that in front of black judge all
right other stuff ok we teased in the
top of the show
Supergirl yes Supergirl you did
something amazing on just the recent
episode that aired just the other night
you download it or you just go watch him
sure they're anywhere near the Internet
someone in your world through this
picture at you yeah oh my lord
me and Mark got to see it we interviewed
Andrew Kreisberg it's like Christ
without the T Kreisberg who runs flash
he was on green arrow he's doing legends
of tomorrow fantastic guys on the
podcast this week got fat man I'm Batman
the long interview with them in any
event he was over and he was talking
about something that was about to happen
on Supergirl and we were like what he
goes want me spoiler and we were like
yes I can't tell you but I could show
you and he showed that picture and we
were like
world is a big amazing time folks for
those that were like who is that that's
john jones the martian manhunter
[ __ ] listen to the dancing part
of the show shame on you
he is an integral member of the Justice
League everywhere but in the Zack Snyder
universe they're not touching that
character yet who cares they're touching
it on Supergirl so if you're like who's
gonna do Jon Jones they did it and they
did it beautifully so good watch that
scene right for that everything is maybe
the business oh there's a Supergirl I've
seen you think that's where they've hit
their life like and it takes every show
a little bit of time to like Irene
here's the characters here's the actors
use what they're good at here's what
stories we can tell well hmm and that
one felt like the one where they found
the gear it's beautiful man I I'm in now
I think the show has had you know the
Berlanti stuff is so close to the comics
it's crazy
we talked as we found out from talking
to Andrew they're all a bunch of [ __ ]
DC nerds over there so they love
throwing in little references that then
grow into all storylines he talks about
like mentioning Nanda Parbat
which eventually led to them getting
Ra's al Ghul in arrow because bit by bit
they're like well League of Shadows and
League of Assassins they had he has a
future the guys trains them and they
finally get their hold on it's crazy I
love that it was basically they were
conning Warner Brothers into letting
them have stuff by including these
little nuggets that the execs wouldn't
recognize by the way we've said all this
we gotta come correct we told them about
Nanda Parbat League shadows and oh I'm
such a good time over there
but the Supergirl seems to be no
exception and he told us stuff that
they're doing for the rest of the season
which is like get on board right now man
forget it the Berlanti versus they're
just doing their until they're crushing
on TV and Marvel crushing over on
Netflix you don't even have to go the
movie theater any no I got getting more
excited about this [ __ ] like flash I
downloaded the smart I didn't watch it
live I've downloaded it's like subscribe
on iTunes and wake up 5 mm bug ablaze
and watch that show it's perfection dude
I look forward more to that than like
Batman V Superman I'm not putting Batman
V Superman down I'm just saying like I
know what to expect either show consists
yeah quality we watch this week's
episode watch this week's this week's
episode of the flash had me crying three
times and a lot of people like stop
crying at this [ __ ] can't help but I'm
an old man I smoke too much weed there's
a father and there's so much dad stop
that's the stuff that always come first
the first thing that really hit me
emotionally was when paddy start stung
story about her dad getting killed
because suddenly or like this classic
comic Secret Origins up yeah and she
instead of putting on a mask
she went into Lauren congressman and
then they paid that off in the third act
another emotional beat where you know
she's she's cuffs buried to the ground
he's flash who knows Baria with this
like an electronic leg cuff yeah which
is metahuman is really cool to be right
but and then she just goes to shoot
somebody else Boyle if you haven't seen
it she goes to shoot somebody and bury
kind of talked her out of it very
emotionally really beautifully pudding
you can see the struggle I love that
actress she's tremendous yeah I've never
seen her before she's great she's that
more of her yeah I love the fact that's
so good the way they construct that
scene is that she's divulging she's
exposing her heart to the flash not
knowing that it's Barry so Barry has
information that she doesn't know he has
right like it's it's that awesome like
who's got the secret like somebody's got
to know a thing that the other person
doesn't know kind of in any scene that
you want to do and now he's got the
secret mm-hmm and it's great it's so
great because now he's conflicted but I
know the stuff about you that I
shouldn't know and and watching him
wrestle with that it's awesome see
that's why I had this guy on the show
man writer he thinks like a writer I'm a
writer I don't think I watch the show
and I just go so good oh good that
slapped myself mark sitting there break
it down and go so of course it's good
because here's why knows how to
construct a story mr. smart
third big cry moment in that show they
say for the third act and is also a huge
addition to the world of the flash and
if you know the world of flash those you
get excited because the future the
introduction of Wally West yeah I teased
it for a few episodes we learned that he
was gonna be gay actors gonna be cast
anybody know the actor's name
I don't were those people wait Liam
McIntyre doesn't and that's the weather
with pinion Lonsdale Canyon Lonsdale
like any Lonsdale basically it gets
introduced in the tail 30 minutes of the
show like they mention him for a little
bit and they say his name was Wallace
well that was my father that's what
we're gonna name you if you were I've
seen was beautiful like they'd haven't
done a [ __ ] town with iris this season
compared to last season where it was all
iris all the time so she they gave her a
really nice scene with Jesse and as iris
and her debt
Joe talking about she comes to grips
finally sells him like you have a son
and he nailed it it was wonderful Jesse
Martin is so good such a good actor you
can hand him that scene which like you
know you might hand another act of that
scene and in like one of these TV shows
and be like I was ridiculous like this
very soap opera that's what occurred to
me when I was watching this episode I
was like this is this is yeah a soap
opera totally literally this is like
addictive like my grandma was addicted
to the young and the restless' and stuff
and they put in all the elements and the
Whale I got sometimes I see my
grandmother cry too so problem be like
what are you now or are gonna get back
together it's fun yeah but now I do the
same thing we're like they know how to
play me man like they do that scene he
opens the door and you see Wally and and
he's talking to Joan you just look at
Jesse's expression his performance it's
wonderful yeah and I can they've got to
the point on that show where they can
earn a season finale being an emotional
beat like it's there's no like super bad
guy they've got a fight there's no like
the world is and colliding that you know
tornadoes aren't ripping the city a
party it's excellent at this point it's
just holy [ __ ] this is what this means
to this family that's your crater and
that was and that was you're so right
man that's how they went out on their
mid-season break essentially well there
was a little post scriptum zoom but they
always do that but the aside from now is
very juicy addition to the flash
universe because for those that don't
know come on how do you not know he's a
flash he becomes bali west becomes a
flash which they can have you know in
the comics buried dies and but they've
hinted that crisis like it's exciting
because it just means like oh my god
they're following like the trajectory
they're doing it right
yet again and go let's not episode of
fat man I'm Batman the audio version
Christ Berg's a genius oh yeah
oh he takes us through the arrow takes
us through flash and then takes us
through legends tomorrow let's talk
about the other aspects applies and then
we got to get out of here here because
that story was great but Mark Hamill
came back is the trickster here more
importantly he was minutes before force
awakens opens good December you know
sometimes you hit a streak and whatnot
or you sit there in life guard could
just use a win marks having a month of
wins right now it's crazy man
high-profile parts and then the weather
wizard came back and of course captain
cold who Jason Mewes loves I think I
think he's great I think it's wonderful
acting Jason Mewes is obsessed with them
he's just like that guy's the best actor
I've ever seen in my life like alright
fair enough but you have worked with
Floyd gallon Rick the same know that guy
he makes that cap call I wish I was
captain Cole Captain Cold such a cool
character man he's cool so I give it up
to that actor and I look they did a
prison break with the guy who was on
Prison Break
what do you mean explain Wentworth
Miller his first TV gig was as the lead
in prison break as they were the two
brothers who were caught in prison
prison break it with Prison Break guy in
it and Jason Mewes was a fan of Prison
Break so it all now it's all coming
together oh my god but anyway if you
haven't watched flash flash flash this
week it's phenomenal last thing that's
it or does it oh my god we've done with
DC man if you want to hear more come
back next episode in a couple days and
we're doing fat man on Batman catch-all
everything which includes like Star Wars
and whatever else
genre stuff we're anything we can do the
wrap-up and next week man we're gonna be
doing like I'm gonna be on the road but
I'm gonna send in we'll do our episode
of force awakens reactions so I might
where I'm in the wall shot a camera in
my face so make sure you come back
tell your parents that I want to watch
that as well bring the kids yeah they're
gonna be a good time but so thanks for
hanging out with us here in the Fatiha
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith follow
mark barnard in here at mark Barden with
a seat with on Twitter or hopefully
he'll return soon from Montreal never
come tell my friend yeah follow me on
that Kevin Smith if you will of shower
that man we'll see you next time here in
the fact cave same fat time same fat
channel youtube.com/ we're still
forgotten we're getting good at this
hey thanks for watching fat man i'm
batman turkeys you want to see more of
this subscribe to my channel click below
tell your friends join us in the fat
cave all sizes welcome all are welcome
crossover children all are welcome